[موسيقى]
روسيا في مشكله بسبب حربها العدائيه في
اوكرانيا وحقيقه جلبهم لاسلحه من ايران
واطلاقها ضد اهداف في اوكرانيا يدفعون
جميعا لتاملي في ضعف القدرات العسكريه
الروسيه وما يقلقني اكثر من ذلك بصراحه هو
تدفق التكنولوجيا الى ايران من روسيا هذا
الامر مقلق جدا سبق ان تحدثنا قليلا عن
احتمال تزويدهم بالطائرات المقاتله وكذلك
هناك احتمال لتزويدهم بالمكونات المتقدمه
التي بامكانها تعزيز قدراتي صواريخهم
البالستيه والقدرات الاخرى المقلقه لنا
جميعا هذا امر مقلق جدا لنا جميعا
[موسيقى]
لقد حافظنا على ما سميته بوضعيه ردع
متباينه بدائران منذ سنوات عديده وقد
تمكنا خلال لها من منع العديد من الهجمات
من قبل دوله ايران ووكلائها ومنعنا ايران
من استخدام المنظمات الارهابيه لتحقيق
اهدافها اعتقد ان هذه الوضعيه لا تزال
قائمه ولكن دائما هناك اشياء بوسع من
القيام بها وعلى شكل خاص في مجال الدفاع
الجوي والصاروخي
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي في هذه امور علينا الاستمرار
بالعمل على تحسينها مع اصدقائنا وشركائنا
في المنطقه ليس فقط فيما يخص اسلحتهم
وقدراتهم كذلك في اسلوب مشاركه المعلومات
[موسيقى]